can can you help me understand like when
you walked in here you said you're a
little bit of a mentalist was that real
like is that I was kind of [__] with
you I going to say like can you [__]
explain to me how they can look at
somebody's face did I see to you when
when you walked in I think I forgot you
said you were like oh you got married at
the White Chapel yeah yeah yeah but but
but then I'm because I'm like dude when
somebody like looks at somebody and
they're just like write down the name of
their dog and show to like what the [__]
is that it's all [__] okay there is
no got to say take me undercover with
you this will be a show let's go
undercover to like you know tarot card
readers people are going to read your
palm and we'll go sit there and I'll
have a little camera and I'll like
completely exposed it's all cold reading
it's all [__] like somebody says hey
it's listen it's magic it's tricks it's
Illusions it's all of that stuff you
know Houdini spent what half of his life
debunking yeah because his mom yeah like
1926 he died but his mom died and he
lost his mom he super upset about that
and uh was he he he so wanted to
communicate with her and like all the
Seance people yeah the mediums would be
like oh your mom's talking to me and and
then he realized that they were using
the same tactics that he would employ
doing tricks so he exposed them and then
he got sued and he would go to court and
so his half of his life that's what he
did he battled these people so when he
died in 1926 on Halloween he said to his
wife beess I'm going to give you a
word because people are going to claim
that they connected to me and contacted
me asked them what what I'm telling
telling you telling them to give to tell
you and so basically they held the
Seance for 10 years it was a vigil it
was um in California on top of the I
think the rat hotel and um right where
my star is by the way which was cool
that they tied it together with Houdini
but uh they had a 10-year vigil there
Seance and eventually his uh wife blew
out the light and said that no one was
capable of making that connection and
the word that they had before he died
that he told his wife would be is the
word believe
and in the word believe in the center of
that word is
lie so none of them um that's funny hey
we're contacting you what's what is he
saying believe no one did that yeah what
about that guy that would the great
Randy James Randy yeah I knew him I know
James Randy when I was 17 years old I
had a cable access show called Hot
kicks uh back in the day in Brook Haven
New York I uh had him on and he was the
one who came up with me confirming to be
called uh Chris Angel no [__] yeah my my
real name is Christopher Nicholas
sendos then I had Santos then I had
sarantis and then I was thinking about
angel he's like Angel that's a great
name for you you look nothing like an
angel and you have birds in your show
and and I I kept it and uh I've known
him uh for many many years he was always
very kind to me he passed um but uh but
he started a foundation that debunked or
proved that it that he that what people
claimed to be psychic or Supernatural
that he couldn't reproduce or explain
how it worked and he did that when he
died the guy that started running his
foundation is a guy is a dear friend of
mine
banich um who um runs that foundation
and uh they have a million dollars for
anybody that can do anything that can't
be EXP explained or reproduced and then
I jumped in I put a million dollars on a
line a couple of times to uh to offer to
like some of the Long Island psychic and
all these people just to and they just
run they just run yeah I mean you
remember watching that documentary with
me when he would just like go on The
Today Tonight Show or whatever it was
and these people would come out and he's
like okay why don't you do this and
you'll like put a box around it and they
can't do like I just it's just I'm not
feeling it today or we're going to move
this pen with our mind and he said okay
and he would take like little styrofoam
and put it on there and said okay move
the pen and not with the styrofoam
because one of the techniques is is that
you blow on the table which makes the
pen go in reverse um or there's some
other technique so like you know you he
was on Johnny Carson and he had a guy
named origel on who I did a show with
and origel claimed that he could Bend
forks and silverware and all of these
different things and then when I was in
in front of him I said on television I
said okay I'll give you a million
dollars Bend this Fork right now cuz I I
bend Forks all the time no show me and
he wouldn't do it and he claimed that it
was a tri if I do it now it's a trick
you know but what I did back then was
and I was just like so kind of exposed
that it was [__]
um I do want to push back though because
I feel like there have been some really
pretty credible psychic
things I'll give you an example my dad
went to see a
psychic um with at the time my stepmom
the psychic said your your first
wife um needs to be set
free because her ashes have not been
spread right like so the
psychic knew that my dad a had a first
wife B's first wife is dead and the the
the ashes were sitting in an n on uh a
shelf in my sister's bedroom closet
because we just hadn't come up with an
idea for for spreading these ashes okay
so um you ever buy uh a car and as soon
as you take it out on the road you
realize oh there's my car over there
there's my car over there you ever and
but when you don't have that car you
never noticed that so here's what
happens it's basically called cold
reading so you weren't there actually
listening to the chain of events and if
I guarantee you if you videotape that
and you listen to the playback um you
would see and I could point out exactly
the method of how they do it they they
talk about a lot of things people have
Expressions body language they're
engaged they might even say something so
if I'm talking General en generalizing
about different things and I see that
you have an interest in something I'm
going to feed off of your body language
how you react your facial expressions if
you respond to me and I'm going to
constantly go and go further and further
once I hit something I'm going to start
going more in that direction and I'm
going to start digging and trying to see
okay which path am I going I'm changing
paths constantly then at the end of that
process
you're going to leave there and the only
thing you're going to remember is what
you want to remember that's important to
you that's why Houdini had such a
problem with people taking advantage of
people that lost the loved one because
people would go to psychic and say I
love this person I miss him and people
would take the psychics would take these
people these vulnerable people their
money and
essentially just give them false hope
and just read them and respond to
them based on the information that they
were gathering while they were talking
to that person it's called cold reading
and it's just you know I've hypnotized
you know what 150 people to remove their
clothes um I've I've done a lot of these
things I've exposed this stuff it is you
know the sad part about it is is that we
take this and it doesn't become just
entertainment or a trick anymore we're
taking this and we're putting such a
value on it and we're putting a value on
it because it goes to our heart with
somebody that we love and this most
intimate connection that we have is
humans and
now I'm exposing that it's [__] and
now you feel like oh my God this thing
that I thought it it's kind of like when
you find out Santa Claus as a kid it's
there's no Santa Claus I can assure you
if people had the ability to do that why
on
910 they did not predict 911 MH why are
they sitting there trying to take $10
$20 $40 for a reading when they can
literally just predict what a lottery
would be I mean there's so many reasons
and so many facts but for me being
somebody who's been doing magic since I
was six years old and I'm not a
specialist in anything I'm a general
practitioner but I
know a bit about all the different
disciplines within the art um from my P
perspective I would love to see anyone
do
something for me me couple people I have
a lot of respect for that we can't
explain it or reproduce it have you ever
been and we put our we put our money on
the line for
that